i can ask you a ridiculous question
please what do you think is the meaning
of life
well i i feel terrible having to give
you the answer i realize you asked the
question but if i tell you you're gonna
again
feel that i don't want to do that but
look there's two there can be a
disappointment there's no
it's gonna be a horror right because we
actually know the answer to the question
oh no it's completely meaningless
there is nothing that we can do that
escapes
the heat death of the universe or
whatever it is that happens at the end
and we're not going to make it there
anyway but even if you
were optimistic about our ability to
escape every
existential hazard
indefinitely ultimately it's all for not
when we know it
right that said once you
stare into that abyss and then it stares
back and laughs or whatever happens
right then the question is okay given
that
can i relax a little bit right and
figure out well what would make sense if
that were true
right and i think there's something very
clear to me
i think if you do all of the you know if
i just take the values that i'm sure we
share
and extrapolate from them i think the
following thing is actually a moral
imperative
being a human and having opportunity
is absolutely [ __ ] awesome right a
lot of people don't make use of the
opportunity and a lot of people don't
have
opportunity right they get to be human
but they're too constrained by
keeping a roof over their heads to
really be free
but being a free human is fantastic and
being a free human on this beautiful
planet crippled as it may be
is unparalleled i mean what could be
better how lucky are we that we get
that right so if that's true
that it is awesome to be human and to be
free then
surely it is our obligation to deliver
that opportunity to as many people as we
can
and how do you do that well i think i
know what job one is
job one is we have to get sustainable
the way to get the maximum number of
humans to have that opportunity
to be both here and free is to make sure
that there isn't a limit on how long we
can keep doing this that effectively
requires us to reach sustainability
and then at sustainability you could
have a
horror show of sustainability right you
could have a totalitarian sustainability
that's not the objective the objective
is to liberate people
and so the question the whole fourth
frontier question frankly
is how do you get to a sustainable and
indefinitely sustainable state
in which people feel liberated in which
they are
liberated to pursue the things that
actually matter to pursue
uh beauty truth
compassion connection all of those
things that we could list as
unalloyed goods those are the things
that people should be most liberated to
do in a system that really functions
and anyway my point is
i don't know how precise that
calculation is but i'm pretty sure it's
not wrong
it's accurate enough and if it is
accurate enough then
the point is okay well there's no
ultimate meaning but the proximate
meaning is that one how many people can
we get to have this wonderful experience
that we've gotten to have
right and there's no way that's so wrong
that if i invest
my life in it that i'm making some big
error yeah sure that
life is awesome and we want to spread
the awesome as much as possible
yeah you sum it up that way spread the
awesome spread the awesome so that's the
fourth frontier and if that fails if the
fourth frontier fails
the fifth frontier will be defined by
robots and hopefully they'll learn the
lessons
uh that the of the mistakes that the
humans made
and build a better world i hope very
happy here and that they do a better job
with the place than we did
but i can't believe it took us this long
uh
to talk as i as i mentioned to you
before
that we haven't actually spoken i think
at all
and i i've always felt that we're
already friends
i don't know how that works because i've
listened to your podcast a lot
i've also sort of uh loved your brother
and so like it it was like we've known
each other for the longest time and
i hope we can be friends and talk often
again i hope to that you get a chance to
meet some of my robot friends as well
and fall in love
and i'm so glad that you love robots
as well so we get to share in that love
so i can't wait for us
to interact together so we went from
talking about some of the worst failures
of humanity
to so some of the most beautiful aspects
of humanity
what else can you uh ask for from a
conversation thank you so much for
talking today
you know lex i feel uh the same way
towards you and i really appreciate it
this has been a lot of fun and i'm
looking forward to our next one
you